una navidad atípica y con drásticas
restricciones para su celebración en el
vaticano la tradicional misa de gallo
que se celebraba a media noche en medio
de una ola de turistas y fieles este año
se adelantó dos horas para cumplir con
el toque de queda y fue presenciada por
apenas unos 200 fieles en la basílica de
san pedro
los miles de extranjeros que acuden en
masa cada 24 de diciembre a belén lugar
en el que según la fe católica fue el
nacimiento de jesús esta vez se
mantuvieron alejados debido a las
restricciones para frenar los contagios
de kobe 19 en américa latina' que
alberga a casi la mitad de los 1300
millones de católicos en el mundo según
el vaticano este tipo de medidas no
fueron la excepción en ecuador las
celebraciones se adelantaron y redujeron
su aforo al 30 por ciento es una
oportunidad tal vez de agradecer el
hecho de estar con salud con vida el
hecho de mantener la calma a pesar de la
crisis que estamos afrontando incluso en
mexico las figuras del tradicional
pesebre portaron mascarillas para enviar
un mensaje a la población aunque no es
debido de que podamos pasar o así yo
pueda venir como con toda mi familia
pues igual es una sensación linda poder
ver aunque sea está adornado porque si
se dan cuenta no está como mucho el
ambiente pues navideño con los años
anteriores
entonces poder ver esto es muy lindo
sin embargo el kobe 19 no apagó el
espíritu navideño la versión animada de
santaclós no detuvo su tradicional
recorrido por el mundo repartiendo
regalos y las calles lucieron iluminadas
ahora la humanidad se prepara para un
fin de año que nunca llegó a imaginar